it's great
hi I'm Robbie the robot hi it's great to
meet you thank you so much for joining
me today my pleasure thank you very much
for having me
I like your design you have a kind of uh
there's a stove light quality to your
mouth especially there's a sort of
almost seems like a heating element you
know so first most important question
iPhone Windows Phone or Android iPhone
Twitter or Facebook
neither they're both good companies but
I I'm not I'm not on either Mac or PC
Mac talking or texting texting we really
enjoy season three of Portlandia tell us
about who's we oh I made me it's okay
thank you very much by the way that's
very very nice of you so tell us about
your guest starts this season how did
you get them to go on the show you know
usually through pretty normal channels
you know we'll tell our producer hey we
really would like to have Chloe Sevigny
on the show can you get ahold of their
agent but sometimes it's like that
sometimes it's just a matter of you know
texting so in season one we had a me man
we just texted her and said you want to
come down and do the show and how do you
change the characters that they play we
let them choose it will say hey jeff
goldblum you know you own an art store
or a doily store they pretty much
figured out that for themselves because
you get I think we get a good
performance that way
you started out as a musician they feel
that playing music live helps with your
comedic timing and your ability to
improvise yeah I mean it's it's also
similar you know playing in a band is
very much like playing you know being in
a scene with other comedians and each
sketch is kind of like a song and an
album we treat season kind of like an
album as well so it all comes together
and then when I was playing drums in a
band you know you just sort of get used
to being on stage and trying to try to
entertain people Portlandia and Saturday
Night Live does it ever feel like too
much do you ever feel like a robot it's
never enough it's so fun yes I do feel
like a robot but that's a positive thing
I want to feel like a robot it must be
amazing being a robot you know it's like
there's a blueprint for the way you're
made and point to different wires and go
like okay this is what helps me do this
I mean it's great it's great do robots
want to travel do you guys have like a
sort of wanderlust do you feel like you
and other robots are of one nation or do
you feel like oh that's a Japanese robot
that say the a bow or whatever it is
that I pronounce it at I bow a bow is
that like ooh that's a foreign robot or
are you like no no we're all brothers I
don't know what you've heard
I didn't mention uprising well I don't
know why you're getting defensive about
it I said do you want to travel and do
you think of yourself as brothers that
uprising never came into I never said
the word uprising never mind
do any do any robot depictions make you
upset does there's anything that you're
like that is not what we're about
not really we haven't been slandered by
Hollywood there's some times where I
think that they they make robots out to
be cold and I don't believe that robots
are cold now we have hearts as opposed
to me I don't have a heart do you ever
think about what you might want to do in
addition to or after you didn't want to
address that I yours that was your cue
to go like yes you do have a heart
you've got a big heart for it thank you
oh that's really nice thank you
they talk a lot in season 2 of Portland
about Battlestar Galactica are you a fan
yes absolutely it's more than just
science fiction it's bigger than that
yeah and I like the Cylons I imagine you
do can you tell the difference in a
Cylon and a human sometimes give or
watch and like did you know some people
we're Cylons before the audience day
because you've just got that sort of
robotic sense of things yeah there's
there's sort of like robot dog don't see
my impression of a Cylon yeah hi how are
you i'm fred armisen would you ever date
the Cylon yeah
really absolutely which one and what's
what's the hinting I mean Cylon is just
a robot right kind of I guess
technically but also there's something
there is some biology to two Cylons
somewhat even though you know there's
something it's like it's kind of a gray
area Starbuck was very dateable I would
say I mean that was the respect that I
mean it like a she's very dateable I
mean more like that was a very good
character I like how focused she was you
know they wouldn't call you too much
Starbuck
she would not call
about 30 rock is ending do you have any
thoughts about the end of that show
definitely one of the best shows ever to
have been on TV I think that watching 30
rock is like it's almost like a drug the
jokes are so fast there are so many
jokes that I get mad I go
that's so good brilliant you know
hopefully there'll be a day when all
comedy is all robots
there should be comedians who perform
only for robots I'm saying human
comedians that only perform for robots
when you guys have your time off you sit
down where at wherever club you guys go
to and it's all robot based humor you
know things like should we get
programmed wrong or like how about being
powered down that's not fun right all
right guys all right how about these
sound effects they put in us right a
little loud like turn down my volume
thank you very much this robot knows
what I'm talking about
you